people ask me all the time though I lack
discipline how can I get discipline in
my life and no one wants to hear this
answer no one wants to Europe find your
passion
thank you like what am I supposed to do
with that advice he made a hundred
thousand went to making six hundred
thousand dollars in three years yeah
that's that's a jump yet want to be
happy
build a life not just a business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you as
well you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best belief life and learn the five
lessons that you must learn before it's
too late
enjoy okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one have a strict sleeping
schedule with jockle willing from my
perspective when people ask me all the
time though I lack discipline how can I
get discipline in my life and no one
wants to hear this answer no one wants
to hear it do it the one of the first
steps you can take to impose discipline
in your life is to wake up early in the
morning because let's face it when the
alarm goes off you're you got your head
on that soft pillow it's all nice and
cozy and warm in there you do not feel
like getting up and so you doesn't even
have a snooze alarm he doesn't ever hit
the snooze engine you should not you
should not bet snooze alarm is insane I
call that snooze alarm the dream killer
like when you put on you when you press
that snooze button you're killing your
dreams so don't don't touch this button
now some would say that might be a
little extreme know where people get
worried and people freak out yeah is
sleep is healthy sleep is good for you I
know that I get it and people say you're
telling people not to sleep no I'm not
telling people not to say you do six
hours every night 10 o'clock yeah I
usually go to bed around 10:30 11:00 and
I wake up at 4:30 so I get five and a
half to six hours almost every night you
know
and sometimes I tell people I I think
sleeping is good I do it almost every
single day but but people will freak out
and say you're telling people to be on
healthy I'm not saying that at all I'm
not you know if you need different
people are they have different genetic
needs for sleep I'm one of those people
that doesn't need much of my four kids
my oldest daughter needs even less sleep
than I do my middle daughter sleeps more
like my wife my son somewhere in the
middle which by the way that means my
middle daughter she gets out of bed when
you get her out of bed in the morning
she likes to sleep so I'm not telling
people hey don't sleep
but I am saying put yourself on a
schedule and you know you ask why I
don't sleep in if you sleep in if I
sleep on in on a Saturday until six
o'clock ooh that night I'm gonna have
more energy and instead of going to bed
at 10:30 or 11:00 I'm gonna stay up
until midnight because I got a little
bit extra sleep well now that next day
I'm gonna sleep in a little bit more
than all of a sudden Sunday I'm sleeping
in until 7 o'clock now Sunday night I
can't go to bed until 1 o'clock in
morning him you see where I'm going with
this I go into Monday with a lack of
sleep because I couldn't fall asleep so
I just the most important thing is set a
good wakeup time that works for you
where you get enough sleep and then wake
up that time every day if you can
lesson number two redefine how you think
about passion with simon Sinek the
problem with passion you know people
gave me the same stupid advice do what
you love thank you thanks you know find
your passion thank you like what am I
supposed to do with that advice you know
and and what I learned is is that
passion like profit as a result when we
commit ourselves to some higher purpose
some higher cause passion is the result
when we work hard for something we don't
believe in it's called stress we work
hard for something we do believe in it's
called passion passion is not the entry
point is that the exit point so the
question is not to find your passion or
find the thing you're passionate about
the question is what do you believe the
mission is what are your ideals what are
your values and where are the places in
which those people are those
organizations share your values share
your beliefs who is articulating a
vision of the world that you would like
to live in push yourself in those
directions be around those people you
know align yourself with those
organizations and what you will find is
you show up every day with passion also
if you want to have more self love and
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links to join on the
description
it's about what you're saying to
yourself but it also comes at work so
whenever I was getting beat down
physically mentally spiritually whatever
I was going through just saying you know
I would put you know you can't hurt me
young people from the toughest
backgrounds who never stopped believing
in their dream people want to know how
to stop the laziness and they will know
how to stop the procrastination lesson
number three stop being a perfectionist
with brené Brown how many of you
struggle with perfectionism a little bit
okay so my favorite story is that
someone sent me an email one time that
said hey I know you have a book on shame
not so interested in that but when if
you have a write on perfectionism I
can't wait so here's the here's the
secret
when perfectionism is driving shame is
always riding shotgun and fear is the
annoying backseat driver say it again
when when perfectionism is driving shame
is always riding shotgun we struggle
with perfectionism in areas where we
feel most vulnerable to shame does that
make sense so we're all comfortable
saying you have a little perfectionist
ik which is code for like I do things
really well but I don't really I'm not
comfortable saying I have shamed
perfectionism what is that I call it the
20-ton shield here's what perfectionism
really is it's a way of thinking that
says this if I look perfect live perfect
work perfect I can avoid or minimize
criticism blame and ridicule whoa that's
good
all perfectionism is is the 20-ton
shield that we carry around hoping that
it'll keep us from being hurt when in
truth what it does is it keeps us from
being seen and so we had a great talk
about what's the difference between
perfectionism yes because somebody on my
staff had the nerve to tell me that I
was a perfectionist and I absolutely
deny that and you stood by me thank you
very much
I'm not perfectionist I'm a person who
strives for excellence and requires
excellence there there is a difference
is there not there is a difference
here's the difference because sometimes
I'm a healthy Stryver yeah and sometimes
I'm a perfectionist it depends on if I'm
feeling if I've got a worthiness crunch
going on so healthy striving is
internally focused it's I want to do
this and be the best I can be
perfectionism is not about what I want
it's perfectionism is exactly what will
people think
lesson number four change your standards
with David Goggins I work with the guy
who's in a business like this for five
years I'm not gonna mention his name
yeah he called me up five years ago to
say I want you to work with me yeah his
job a big day for them was if you had
five meetings in 40 calls $40.00 that
was like according to their big business
plan that was a day yeah he said I want
to make more money um all this just bug
you know is this bogging me down I said
this is your day five meetings and 40
calls like have you do you start at ten
and he's got four and and this company
you work for says dick this is a great
day this is what we want
I had this guy know one day he made a
thousand cold calls it had seven
meetings yeah so his new norm which is
now the company how did you become he
made a hundred thousand went to making
six hundred thousand dollars in three
years
yeah that's that's the jump he had just
because his mindset change because the
company put this label this is what is a
good day a good day is 40 calls five
means I said that's a bullsh day cuz
you're comparing yourself with mediocre
people and go bingo do not run with
mediocre people I'm going to tell you
how to beat these mediocre people this
is your new 300 dials and eight meetings
yeah and his whole world changed and
lesson number five the last one before a
very special bonus lesson is chart your
own course with Michelle Obama at 6 a.m.
every morning I had to get on a city bus
and ride
for an hour sometimes more just to get
to school and I was willing to do that
because I was willing to do whatever it
took for me to go to college I set my
sights high I decided I was going to
Princeton but I quickly realized that
for me a kid like me getting into
Princeton wasn't just gonna happen on
its own
see I went to a great school but at my
school we had so many kids so few
guidance counselor's they were dealing
with hundreds of students so they didn't
always have much time to help me
personally get my applications together
plus I knew I couldn't afford to go on a
bunch of college visits I couldn't hire
a personal tutor I couldn't enroll in
SAT prep classes we didn't have the
money and then get this some of my
teachers straight up told me that I was
setting my sights too high they told me
I was never going to get into a school
like Princeton I still hear that doubt
ringing in my head so it was clear to me
that nobody was gonna take my hand and
lead me to where I needed to go instead
it was gonna be up to me to reach my
goal I would have to chart my own course
now I have a special bonus clip from
Will Smith on how to conquer your fears
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one where do
you need to change your standards number
two where do you need to stop being a
perfectionist and number three what's
the strict sleeping schedule you will
start tonight and if you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments as well skydiving is a really
interesting confront with fear
[Applause]
you go out the night before and you you
know you take a drink with your friends
and somebody says yeah we should go
skydiving tomorrow and you go yeah we'll
go skydiving yeah and you go home but
you by yourself you like me right you're
like well yeah I mean they was drunk too
so then that night you're laying in your
bed and you just keep and you're
terrified you keep imagining over and
over again jumping out of an airplane
and you can't figure out why you would
do that so you get there and then you
have this safety brief and you're
standing there and the guys to tell you
what the chute doesn't open what's gonna
happen is you're doing you a lot of help
with walk won't get up so you get onto
the airplane and you're sitting there
and you know it's extra because you're
sitting on some dudes lap some stranger
trying to make small talk yeah man so
you could be you be jumping with people
all the time huh so you fly and you go
up to 14,000 feet and somebody opens the
door and in that moment you realize
you've never been in a freaking airplane
with the door open
terror terror terror talent and then
people start going out of the airplane
and the guy walks you up to the end of
the thing and you're standing at your
toes are on the edge and you're looking
out down to death they say on three two
and he pushes you on to because people
grab one three
and you fall out of the airplane
and in one second you realize that it's
the most blissful experience of your
life you're flying
there's zero fear you realize at the
point of maximum danger is the point of
minimum fear the lesson for me was why
were you scared in your bed the night
before what do you need that fear for
everything's up to this stepping out
there's actually no reason to be scared
and then in that moment all of a sudden
where you should be terrified is the
most blissful experience of your life
and God placed the best things in life
on the other side of fear
if you want to learn the 10 Universal
skills that are hard to learn but will
pay off forever
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there every
morning I go for a run that's the first
and do every morn you haven't taken a
day off of running since December 2016